[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 7 mai elles étaient
attendues elles sont désormais
utilisables l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a inauguré ce
vendredi 7 mai son service de
trottinettes électriques
un nouveau pas vers la mobilité durable
à dimanche 9 mai ce sera la journée
internationale de l'europe
l'occasion de parler de l'union
européenne son rôle dans la crise
sanitaire ou encore ses relations avec
les collectivités locales
notre invité à ce sujet beaudoin baudru
chef de la représentation en france de
la commission européenne
enfin comme chaque semaine s'il ya 400
go vous proposera ses idées sorties et
loisirs
juste avant cela les collégiens et les
lycéens ont fait leur rentrée depuis une
semaine après quatre semaines de
fermeture des établissements pour les
élèves de primaire et de maternelle
c'était il y a deux semaines
une rentrée sous protocole renforcé
désormais la fermeture d'une classe est
décrété dès lors qu'un cas positifs de
kobe de 19 et décelés parmi les élèves
ce qui peut expliquer de nombreuses
fermetures au jeudi 6 mai à 13h cent
trente et une classes étaient fermés
dans les yvelines après des données
fournies par l'académie de versailles
quasiment 100 de plus par rapport à il
ya une semaine les fermetures sont
encore plus nombreuses dans les autres
départements de l'académie 179 dans les
hauts de seine
212 dans le val d'oise et même 224 en
essonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
un nouveau service de trottinettes
électriques dans toute l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines sky tiers
mobility a inauguré ce vendredi 7 mai
900 ans jean seront déployés
prochainement dans les 12 communes de
l'agglomération
un sujet de bérangère bourgoin et
bixente ni rien senti stevan testé et
approuvé les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines on inaugurait le nouveau
service cailletière mobility 300
stations réparties sur les différentes
communes de l'agglomération et environ
1000 trottinette dès le mois de mai on
innove sur la troisième génération de
trottinettes qui est très numérique
d'ailleurs qui est beaucoup plus facile
à contrôler et à garer
à utiliser l'idée en tout cas à terme ce
qu'on souhaiterait c'est pouvoir
l'ouvrir aux entreprises là on est sur
le domaine public
on travaille avec les villes avec
l'agglomération mais pourquoi pas les
entreprises demain pourquoi pas les
collèges avec le département pourquoi
pas les lycées avec la région une
première phase d'expérimentation
renouvelables sur 12 mois
l'entreprise tire mobility couvre déjà
l'île de france avec 6000 trottinette en
activité sur la région pourtant saint
quentin en yvelines est un nouveau défi
pour l'opérateur
c'est la première fois qu'un opérateur
se se développe en deuxième couronne
donc pour nous vraiment c'était c'était
l'opportunité d'expérimenter sur un
nouveau type de territoire on trouve que
c'est une solution qui très intéressante
pour le dernier kilomètre utile pour les
trajets courts des saint quentinois
les trottinettes s'ajoute en complément
des nouveaux circuits vélo dans
l'agglomération pour les tarifs ils ont
été réfléchies selon une logique
territoriale
vous avez eu toute une gamme en fait
d'offre commerciale en fonction des
publics
il ya même une offre à destination des
personnes à mobilité réduite qui va
pouvoir se développer avec la start-up
omni il ya des différents types de
tarifs donc on a des tarifs étudiants
qu'on va lancer en septembre
on a aussi un tarif solidaire qui sont
pour ceux qui ont des revenus plus bas
qui ont accès
différents avantages ils pourront aussi
avoir des avantages sur les trottinettes
électriques
quant aux usagers ponctuels ils pourront
débloquer la trottinette pour un euro le
tarif évolue ensuite de 15 centimes
d'euros par minute d'utilisation en cas
d'adoption par les saint quentinois
la société est prête à déployer jusqu'à
2500 trottinette sur le territoire et
l'actualité c'est aussi la journée
internationale de l'europe ce dimanche 9
mai pour parler de cette célébration
mais aussi du rôle de l'union européenne
nous accueillons en visioconférence avec
nous beaudoin baudru bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir à tous vous êtes chef de la
représentation en france de la
commission européenne alors pour rappel
ce 9 mai cette journée internationale de
l'europe ce célèbre la paix et l'unité
en europe il s'agit de la date
anniversaire de la déclaration schuman
le 9 mai 1950 un discours prononcé avant
la naissance de la communauté économique
européenne
dans les yvelines par exemple la
municipalité de vie pro organise
d'ailleurs ce samedi 8 mai une
conférence en ligne sur jean monnet est
le premier pas vers l'unité européenne
anecdotes historiques et découverte des
coulisses explication des grandes dates
qui ont fait l'europe
tout un programme beaudoin baudruche en
quoi est ce important de fêter cette
journée internationale de l'europe
je crois que aujourd'hui peut-être plus
que puisque auparavant quand on voit
comment le monde évolue autour de nous
quand on voit ces régimes autoritaires
qui montrent leurs muscles
pas très loin de chez nous et je pense à
la russie je pense à la turquie un peu
plus loin je pense à à la chine
également
je pense que célébrer l'europe et se
rassembler autour de ses valeurs qui ont
fait ce projet européen depuis 61 71 ans
comme vous l'avez rappelé la déclaration
schuman
c'est quelque chose qui doit nous
mobiliser tous est en effet un projet de
paix de prospérité et de solidarité mais
c'est aussi une communauté de valeurs
je vous invite tous à relire l'article 2
de traité sur l'union européenne il est
très court mais c'est en fait un
inventaire de ce qui nous rassemble
ce qui nous réunit la solidarité la
l'état de droit la protection des
minorités
tout ça fait notre identité nous
européens avec des nuances évidemment
les français ont une culture une
histoire qui n'est pas la même que les
allemands que les irlandais mais on a en
commun toutes ces valeurs tous ces
principes que nous défendons à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne mais
aussi je les envie de dire surtout à
l'extérieur de l'union européenne donc
c'est un c'est un moment de célébration
de 2,7 cette communauté de valeurs que
nous partageons tous collectivement
alors 71 ans vous l'avez rappelé et
cette année l'union européenne s'est du
coup elle est là elle a dû s'adapter
justement par rapport à la crise
sanitaire tout comme ses pays membres
évidemment l'europe a notamment déployé
un plan de relance de 1,8 milliard
d'euros alors 1800 même milliards
d'euros pardon à qui at il bénéficié
dans ce cas de cette crise sanitaire
alors en fait ce plan de relance qui est
composé à la fois d'un d'un paquet
d'argent important 750 milliards que
l'union européenne la commission va
emprunter sur les marchés financiers
pour ensuite transférer vous prêter
cette somme aux états membres et le
budget qui est l'autre partie donc à peu
près de 100 milliards d'euros sur une
période de cette année l'ensemble de ce
paquet où vous avez évoqué va bénéficier
à tous les états membres de et à
plusieurs niveaux
une partie de cet argent va être en fait
à louer au niveau national en fonction
des programmes des politiques qui sont
conduites mais il ya aussi ces
programmes importants qui concernent en
fait le niveau local les régions les
départements voir les municipalités qui
peuvent bénéficier de cofinancement
européen pour mettre en oeuvre un
certain nombre de projets de
développement dans le domaine de la
santé des transports des connexions
internet et aussi de tout ce qui est le
social le social qui est de nouveau au
devant de la scène aujourd'hui en europe
puisque à l'heure où nous parlons se
déroule un sommet social à porto au
portugal puisque le portugal assume pour
le moment la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne et donc le social est
très important aujourd'hui et je crois
qu'il est nécessaire que l'union
européenne et des états membres se se
serrent les mains je vais dire pour
apporter une solution aux défis sociaux
que
la société aujourd'hui y compris ses
défis ses problèmes qui se sont encore
davantage développée à cause de la crise
due cori évidemment exacerbée avec cette
crise sanitaire donc une union
européenne qui ces dates mignon no brain
aussi pardon fragile qui n'a pas de
compétence en matière de santé je le
rappelle de ce fait chaque pays pendant
cette crise a mis un petit peu en place
sa propre politique sanitaire
mais c'est bien l'europe pourtant qui
coordonne le vaccin et les commandes de
vaccins contre le coc u19
est-ce qu'on s'y perd par un peu
justement beaudoin baudru entre voilà
cette compétence santé qui n'existe pas
qu'est ce que l'union européenne peut
faire en ce sens alors vous avez tout à
fait raison de rappeler que jusqu'à
présent et c'est encore comme ça dans
les traités en fait les compétences de
l'union européenne en matière de santé
publique sont très très modeste on est
on a en fonction du traité une
compétence de coordination de
encouragements de promotion de certaines
campagnes par exemple contre le tabac
des choses comme ça mais on n'a pas
beaucoup de moyens pour travailler avec
les états membres pour promouvoir une
véritable union de la santé nous avions
sur la période précédente 450 millions
d'euros en tout et pour tout pour 28
états membres
parce qu'à l'époque le royaume uni est
encore avec nous ce qui fait en fait par
personne par européen 12 centimes
d'euros par an avec ça on peut pas mener
véritablement une politique de santé
publique en europe
heureusement à l'occasion des
négociations budgétaires pour la
nouvelle période qui a commencé au 1er
janvier
les états membres ont accepté en grande
partie en tout cas la proposition de la
commission avec l'aide du parlement
européen pour démultiplier ce budget on
a maintenant un budget de plus de cinq
milliards d'euros à la place de 450
millions pour mener en tout cas une
politique de prévention et de réaction
rapide en fait en cas de pandémie comme
celle que nous connaissons maintenant
donc effectivement nous avons vite
constaté qu' il y a un an chaque état
membre faisait un petit peu apporter des
solutions d'abord orientée vers les
besoins nationaux
alors que nous fonctionnons dans un
marché qui est intégré à 28 maintenant
27 états membres qui lie à des produits
médicaux et des appareils
dicko qui étaient fabriqués dans
d'autres états membres et qui devait
traverser les frontières on avait fermé
les frontières et donc la commission est
intervenue pour proposer non pas des
lois parce qu'on n'a pas la compétence
pour le faire mais des solutions
pratiques pour permettre justement le
flux de marchandises médical notamment
au travers des frontières entre l'union
européenne entre les pays de l'union
européenne est en effet vous avez évoqué
la fameuse stratégie d'achat des vaccins
ce que la commission a voulu éviter à
tout prix c'est que certains pays
puissent obtenir des vaccins et d'autres
pas et notamment les grands pays les
pays où se trouvent des laboratoires de
production de vaccins qui aurait pu être
servis en premier si je puis dire alors
que d'autres ont dû attendre et
peut-être n'auront pas obtenu de vaccins
du tout pendant des mois et des mois
nous avons de préserver l'unité de
l'union européenne justement de
coordonner cette campagne vaccinale
oui parce que en fait la campagne
vaccinale et la production la
distribution des vaccins dans des
conditions de crise telles qu'on les a
connu et qu'on connaît encore un peu
maintenant c'est avant tout une
expression de solidarité on a voulu
permettre que tous les citoyens
européens où qu'ils soient puissent
avoir un accès équivalent au vaccin
alors on a proposé notamment on n'a pas
à décider ça tout seul on a négocié avec
les états membres les états membres sont
partie prenante de ces négociations avec
les laboratoires que on distribuerait
les vaccins au fur et à mesure de leur
mise à disposition au prorata de 2 du
nombre d'habitants partie donc les
grands pays en auront plus mais
simplement parce que les besoins sont
plus grands pas parce que simplement ils
sont plus grands eux mêmes et peut-être
d'un point de vue politique plus
important si vous voulez donc tous les
citoyens européens sont traités de la
même manière et on a aujourd'hui en fait
d'ici la fin du semestre
les premiers semaine 2021 on aura plus
de 500 millions de doses de vaccins qui
auront été distribués dans les 27 villes
de l'union européenne dont 55 millions
du vaccin johnson & johnson qui qui et
qui ne nécessite qu'une qu'une injection
donc on a maintenant vraiment rattraper
le temps perdu un petit peu au début de
cette année parce que il est vrai qu'on
a eu des difficultés en a surtout eu des
mauvaises surprises de la part de
certains laboratoires qui avait pris
mais un certain nombre de millions de
dos et qui tout d'un coup on dit on
n'est pas capable de vous fournir autant
on doit vous fournir un tiers
je pourrai compter a été assez
mouvementée sur sur ce côté là merci en
tout cas vaudois baudru d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce 7e week-end et pour toutes
ces précisions sur l'union européenne
je le rappelle ce dimanche 9 mai la
journée internationale de l'europe en ce
mois de mai également la société
protectrice des animaux la spa lance le
mois de l'adoption
cette opération vise à promouvoir
l'adoption responsable grâce au
savoir-faire des refuges en 2020 sur les
37 1667 adoption seuls 3 8% des animaux
adoptés ont fait l'objet d'un retour
un record qui montre un accompagnement
optimal dans les yvelines les spa vous
accueille dans trois refuges à orgeval
airs murray ou encore plaisir et après
cette semaine bien chargée quoi de mieux
que de se détendre le week end
comme chaque vendredi célia gars de son
go vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons jouer dans les
rues saint-quentinoise 1 explique
guilhem a été créée par unis ni monteyne
pendant le confinement
le but du jeu retrouvé un galet cacher
dans un endroit de saint quentin en
yvelines un montage de lucas audard des
indices cachés dans les villes de
montigny le bretonneux cuit en cours et
voisins le bretonneux pour trouver un
galet scaes cachette à l'escale game que
l'on peut réaliser dans les rues
saint-quentinoise j'ai conçu cette
escape game pour ma famille et mes amis
au départ est comme ça alors beaucoup
plus puis c'est pas le premier que je
fais j'aime beaucoup faire face ben en
fait gelé un peu adapté pour qu'ils
puissent être utilisable par tout le
monde donc il suffit d'imprimer en fait
les ya une quinzaine de pages que j'ai
proposé ensuite on découpe les fiches
s'est expliquée dedans et puis on peut
partir ensuite avec ce kit l'a
directement à la 1ère étape 12 étapes au
total le but trouver les bons numéros et
les reporter dans une grille qui donnera
des coordonnées gps pour trouver le
fameux galles et à lille de loisirs côté
base nautique un indice y est caché je
prends plusieurs jours pour aller sur
des lieux que je connais pas ou que je
connais un peu et puis je cherche des
détails donc je prends des photos
j'essaye de trouver qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être utilisée finalement pour
créer une énigme et si on prend
l'exemple du club de voile qui est juste
derrière nous et ben j'ai essayé de
regarder dans ce bâtiment là qu'est ce
qui pouvait me servir en fait pour créer
l'énigme ses deux filles âgées de 11 et
13 ans l'habitude de jouer aux escales
game de leur maman résine insee
il ya le fait de trouver aussi c'est au
plaisir que j'aime bien
j'aime trop canon fait à chaque fois en
plus quand la voix préparer on a trop
hâte de le faire et tout c'est trop bien
autre endroit à guyancourt cette fois ci
en face du technocentre
c'est l'étape 9 du jeu il faut qu on
compte le nombre de statues vous avez
des neuf les filles c'est ça ouais il ya
une rangée de foi est d'accord on va
aller chercher de trop près à fait sûr
locaux gratuits skype se cacher
disponibles sur les pages facebook des
habitants des communes de saint quentin
en yvelines un lien s'y trouve pour
charger les documents inscriptions
ouvertes pour le village sportif et
culturel de l'île des loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines qui célèbre ses 10
ans du 19 juillet au 6 août plus de 1000
jeunes qui ne partent pas en vacances
vont bénéficier d'au moins 25 activités
différentes
l'accès est gratuit et ouvert également
au grand public si des créneaux
d'activités sont disponibles tour du
programme dans l'interview express avec
vincent couteau le responsable
communication de l'île de loisirs de 50
ans des villes où sur 50 ans on a décidé
de proposer un village de trois semaines
du 19 juillet au 6 août avec avec un
vrai équilibre entre les activités
sportives d'activités culturelles et
certaines victimes étaient libres donc
tout se déroule dans l'espace
événementiel qui est l'ancienne piscine
à vagues
c'est un espace de 4 hectares
entièrement plénière est entièrement
clôturé et sécurisé
accrobranche et j'avais parlé de loisirs
à la voile le canoë en fonction de la
météo à l'équitation est aussi une
petite activité qu'on a un minigolf
présentation pas la telline donc ses
activités gérées mitterrand parlait de
loisirs et ensuite on virage c'est toute
une panoplie d'activités qu'on n'a pas
du tout l'habitude de mettre en place et
là on aura du rugby à 5 du beach
handball du basket ball en 3 contre 3
comme ça ça va être la nouveauté de
cette année puisque c'est une discipline
olympique et sur les activités
culturelles
on aura des initiations aux gestes qui
sauvent
on aura une exposition sur les jeux
olympiques localement on a déjà prévu la
distribution de petits goodies
donc on va essayer utile et qu'ils
soient pas simplement simplement des
petits objets à jeter effectivement
quelques quelques mini événement on
pense déjà des cancers on pense à une
séance de cinéma de plein air avec le
film sur jesse owens pourquoi pas on va
vraiment marquer ses dix ans avec avec
quelques amis des événements en début et
en fin de nuit là j c'est ton buzz avec
les abeilles première édition de cette
manifestation à feucherolles qui se
déroulera du 8 mai au 19 juin
le but sensibiliser les visiteurs sur
les pollinisateurs et les abeilles j.le
thulliez bonsoir bonjour vous êtes
conseiller municipal membre de la
commission environnement et
développement durable à feucherolles
alors pourquoi avoir créé une fête à
l'honneur de la biodiversité dans votre
commune parce que c'est une très belle
opportunité cette année qui est assez
exceptionnel c'est un acte de jeu d'hier
et de résilience par rapport aux
contraintes sanitaires du moment et que
c'est une bonne occasion de mettre en
avant les pollinisateurs notamment les
abeilles en particulier et en même temps
compte tenu de notre position nous ce
choc face à la plaine de versailles
donc on a souhaité mettre ce festival
fait un buzz avec les abeilles pour
mobiliser aussi bien que je parlais que
d'autres intéressés à la biodiversité
voilà alors ça va tourner autour des
conférences ça va tourner aussi avec un
marché thématique le 5 et le 19 juin est
également une fête du village
pour conclure cette période festive
justement on va en parler de tout ça
alors il y aura durant ces six semaines
donc des conférences et des animations
aussi pour les enfants dans les classes
primaires
est ce que d'autres débats justement
seront proposés pour le public lambda
absolument il y à l'heure actuelle six
conférences qui sont programmés dont la
première va commencer ce 8 mai à 14h30
en semis direct nous le ferons nous la
ferons avec monsieur thiam calais de la
gds à lierse qui s'occupe également des
des abeilles et et tu prends un
sanitaire les concernant et des marchés
donc thématique vous l'avez dit seront
aussi au coeur de l'événement qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra y découvrir alors nous
essayons de réunir beaucoup d'acteurs de
la plaine de versailles ça attendra
évidemment autour du miel et de ses
produits dérivés
la propolis la gelée royale la cire et
puis d'autres d'autres artisans qui
tourne autour de la biodiversité que ce
soit des plantes que ce soit aussi une
explication sur le fonctionnement d'une
ruche puisque certains de nos
intervenants viendront est une ruche
sous cloche pour montrer aux enfants
comment tout ça fonctionne toutes ces
petites bêtes ça s'est senti n'est mêlé
comment ça fonctionne et félicitons buzz
avec les abeilles sera donc clôturé par
donc la fête du village on vous l'avait
dit le
9 juin prochain quels seront les
animations proposées lors de cette fête
alors comme nous sommes dans un million
dans un milieu rural ça concernera bien
sûr des jeux simples chambres où tout de
pêche à la ligne de danse ira aussi
également une petite chorale organisé
par l'association musicale de pétrole il
n'y aura le marché par lui-même et et
d'autres activités festives pour les
enfants et de 7 ans eh bien merci
beaucoup j'ai utilisé d'avoir été notre
invité merci beaucoup
à très bientôt en moi
[Musique]
et pour finir cette page wazir je vous
propose deux activités deux sorties pour
ce week end avec la réouverture de la
base de loisirs des étangs de hollande
en mai l'ouverture se fait tous les
week-ends de 11h à 18h la baignade est
surveillée
vous pourrez aussi bronzée mais la
fréquentation maximale est réduite à 6
125 personnes la deuxième édition de
fête des plantes se déroulera dimanche 9
mai de 9h30 à 18h30 sur le parvis de la
mairie du mesnil-saint-denis 25
exposants dont des horticulteurs rucher
et paysagistes seront présents
des animations sont aussi prévues tout
au long de la journée et les missions
continuer avec lots nord pour parler de
l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'est grégory
canale qui vous la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
la première étape du déconfinement
enclenchée depuis le 3 mai fin de la
limitation des 10 km et de l'attestation
de déplacement les professionnels
regardent désormais vers le 19 mai date
de la réouverture des terrasses des
lieux culturels et des commerces fermés
la campagne de vaccination s'accélère
emmanuel macron a annoncé l'ouverture
aux plus de 50 ans et surtout la
possibilité désormais pour les plus de
18 ans de recevoir une injection
lorsqu'il reste des doses de vaccin pour
ne pas les gâcher a dit le chef de
l'état
l'hommage rendu par les pompiers à leurs
collègues à la caserne de rambouillet le
caporal juste almeida 19 ans s'est tué à
moto le 30 avril qu'il devait participer
au dispositif de sécurité de l'hommage
national rendu à la fonctionnaire de
police stéphane sommes enfermés les
élections départementales sont au
programme les 20 et 27 juin prochains et
les candidats aux scrutins sont
désormais connus dans les yvelines 91
binôme paritaire sont en lice dans les
21 cantons du département 120 joueurs
sur le parcours de l'albatros le links
et européennes se tient jusqu'au 8 mai
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
la particularité du tournoi mais les
golfeurs amateurs et professionnels
enfin cette année c'est le bicentenaire
de la mort de napoléon bonaparte il
s'est éteint le 5 mai 1821 sur l'île de
sainte hélène
le château de versailles possède l'une
des plus importantes collections
napoléonienne 400 tableaux et 200
sculptures dédiée à celui qui fut
empereur de france
[Musique]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end votre
rendez vous comme chaque vendredi en
partenariat avec les surligneurs on
écoute vincent couronne docteur en droit
à l'université versailles saint quentin
et fondateur paix surligneurs
chronique de l'est gagnent chez king où
l'on reparle de la sphère sara lee mis
sauvagement battu puis défenestré par
son voisin qui au moment des faits
proférer des insultes antisémites
le meurtrier a néanmoins été déclaré
pénalement irresponsable par la justice
car au moment des faits son discernement
était aboli président du modem françois
bayrou ancien ministre de la justice
alors exprimé son souhait qu aucune
déclaration d'irresponsabilité ne puisse
être faite sans qu'un débat
contradictoire et lieux ajoutant qu'on
le doit aux victimes et à ceux qui les
pleurent sauf que la proposition de
françois bayrou semble bien inutile
inutile car depuis une réforme de 2008
lorsqu'une personne mise en examen est
sur le point d'être déclaré pénalement
irresponsable
un débat contradictoire peut avoir lieu
devant la chambre de l'instruction de la
cour d'appel débat auquel interviennent
les différentes parties avec
réquisitoire du procureur et en dernier
la parole est à la défense
à la fin de ce mini procès même si
techniquement ça n'en est pas un le juge
rend sa décision dans l' affaire halimi
ce débat contradictoire a bien eu lieu
et le juge a considéré que les charges
retenues contre le mise en examen était
suffisante
en d'autres termes c'est bien lui qui a
tué sarah halimi et ce meurtre avait un
caractère antisémite mais son
discernement était aboli pendant les
faits il n'est pas pénalement
responsable avant la réforme de 2008 il
faut savoir qu'il n'y avait aucun débat
contradictoire la proposition de
françois bayrou et de la bouche de
l'ancien certes éphémère ministre de la
justice
interroge sur la compétence de certains
politiques pour les fonctions qu'ils ont
pu occuper mais ça c'est un autre débat
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi passé un très bon week
end et une très bonne soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]